never one to be afraid of controversy
Alastair Campbell decided to hold a
phone in on the radio this week and
discuss gender equality what could
possibly go wrong
who should call but his own daughter
Grace had a few things to say
he called women birds he was useless
around the house and also didn't like
talking about periods show me a black
who does I'm not bad for 61 he protested
I'm on his side outside the workplace
where's the harm in calling women girls
anyone love or darling or my lover if in
Bristol once a Street trader caught me
blossom not madam and it made my day but
I'm not sure my 24 year old daughter
would like it
maybe we of a certain age have to accept
that we are behind the curve not woke it
could be the younger generation is right
to school us and just as Miss World
contestants are covering up it's time to
make our words as well as our behavior
appropriate to the me to area era excuse
me what do you think my lover's you know
I I despair of the sexist grammar police
I really do you know only urban
sophisticates could object to being
called darling or love or whatever and
Alastair Campbell he's a totally
different case in point he's rude every
time man or woman it doesn't matter what
you yeah well maybe it is just to me but
I do happen to be a woman he's
incredibly rude to me but I just I love
the fact that we call women love and
darling and petal and honey and in
London I had one the other day somebody
calling a woman treacle and I guess
that's because you're sweet and and I
think all of these things are said in
warm affectionate ways and they're part
of the this colloquial colorful language
we haven't I feel I feel you know I feel
sorry for guys who must walk around
terrified of offending people the whole
time terrified so purse slipped woman is
gonna call them a sexist I wanted
tonight osofsky
there was a somebody who had to resign
the other day for saying
lift that he was going to ladies
lingerie I mean are we just getting far
too oversensitivity should we die not a
daughter a bit like yeah who would give
me quite a hard time on certain language
but one like talk about girls yeah I
mean I talk about girl you know she's
nice guy
her view is if you all in your thirties
you're not a girl yeah but you say guys
should we just hear what I'm a good
example that she knows yeah grace how
she schooled him
you still call women birds I think isn't
I think you don't even think about the
impact that that has you know I do that
when you're around men when do that you
do when you're around men you do it when
you're around man I'm something if you
truly want to be a feminine she doesn't
like them using birds but there are
other I think the issues she has is that
there are certain words that we only
apply to women and it is it was a way of
sort of demeaning can I just run through
them abrasive [ __ ] bombshell curvy
ditzy emotional hormonal hysterical
shrill never apply to men I was in the
studio when this happened because I took
over from him after he went off air cuz
it was he was sitting in for night
joining usually I felt sorry for him for
a reason and I don't know the guys the
first time I actually met him in person
the bloke I should say I first time I
met him in person and I don't I just
felt there was something unedifying with
somebody's daughter Corning into I think
it was funny he didn't mention it to no
it wasn't set up and he didn't mention
it to me though I think perhaps the
producers asked her to I don't know but
he didn't know about it I think because
you can tell when before that clip is
when she says hello he instantly
recognizes her voice and starts laughing
and says hello so it was a surprise for
him in terms of his reaction I just want
to say very quickly I see look there are
certain words that we only use for women
birds is one of them but there are
certain words we only is for men i bloke
is one of them right and then girls and
guys blow kiss neutral yeah okay but
what I mean is this is an example I've
many words like that
is quite offensive it may be the only
one I don't like
maybe 56% I've got a little thing here
56% and women want bird band actually
only 56% doll 45% there's a lot of
evidence that in the regions as we call
them you know they say duck or chicken
and in the Midlands and it's quite
normal
just to add these terms of endearment on
and they don't actually they don't color
the sentence at all but like I do that
all the time like I'll call people
sweetheart or kid or or and if you want
to call me a bird like his daughter just
said oh you don't sound the impact I
would impact that husband if someone
calls me a bird or whatever I don't
really care it's like the intention is
but then I then I will be completely
honest and and this probably isn't great
you talk about people will call you like
hey babe or hey sweetheart
I hate if that is relatively
good-looking I don't mind if it is some
fat old you know lecturers looking guy
that's rubbing his thighs whilst he's
calling me babe I have a problem with
that wolf-whistle from a building site
and I can't it's awesome it's nice can I
just bring you mentioned your daughter
and girls okay this is it this is a
quote from Sir Roger gay who bought hell
last week because he was talking about
his wife who works in his office and he
said she's utterly dedicated her job as
indeed are the other girls in my office
everyone went mad because he referred to
these women
he's an MP's Roger Kastle Rajic Olympic
everyone what mad cuz he called these
women girls which i think is you know
when I'm a bit demeaning they didn't
think it is I can I just say what I
think I actually in the end had to write
about that and I thought about that case
really carefully and what I realized was
it's all depending on context you're in
a bar and he/she someone says hello babe
to you but if you're in the office nee
says babe let's say you go girls out in
surgery yeah and the consultant sitting
there let's say he's a man says hello
sweetheart you know you don't want that
you want a sense of formality but the
same with men though I get an aeroplane
and the and the male air steward calls
me
pet or or a darkness because they're gay
right now and it's fine but I wouldn't
expect that in an office all air shoes
as well Tim wants by an asteroid I was
on that bit weird
was he gay though maybe because I see
you know it took me eight when I made a
group of elderly ladies right I go hi
girls I go hi girls
yeah and they quite that's why young
people girls or boys is if someone calls
you something that you're not
comfortable with saying have the balls
to say look I'd prefer you to call me
Michelle or this or that so don't sit
and get offended and analyze impacts of
things if someone's calling you
something just drawler and constantly I
should stop being so precious and silly
about it all it doesn't mean no but
surely it just changes over time and
what was acceptable 2030s go people take
offense that now young people's emotions
and feelings maybe I come from a
different generation where where we
didn't have time to think about your
emotional fusions too much and we spend
too much time worrying about how things
impact on them now somebody calling you
darling I love a petal is not gonna harm
you in any way what I find really
interesting is of course they have their
own distinct mattias words that for an
older generation are still stigmatized
like for example certain swear words and
so it also works in Reverse and I would
say to young people there are certain
words you use that's one older ear would
sound offensive and yeah those same
young people say I'll get over it stop
being so prudish and so I think it works
both ways and this is the way language
of bolts now you mention the older
generation another great advantage of
calling everyone darling is you like
they're doing they say hello darling not
be to see you know I work with the guy
who called all women darling and all men
captain forever called each other once
Technica hello boss whatever even if
he's not your boss yeah sweet it's all
it depends how it's done is it when
Alastair Campbell does it to me it's
aggressive um you know but but other men
calling it did he call you
oh he's called me lots of names over
beautiful oh yeah I did feel sorry for
the pair though no you shouldn't